it's happening every day around the
water cooler people are self-censoring
people are silencing themselves it is
bad for the country
the left is happy about it because they
feel as though they are in control and
they are in control
there is a pew poll that was taken last
year you know what it showed it showed
that the plurality of
every group politically in the united
states outside of woke progressives
believes they have to self-censor every
single one liberals moderate liberals
say that they have to self-censor what
they believe
at work because they're afraid of the
repercussions the only people who never
have to self-censor are the most radical
leftists
those people can say whatever the hell
they want they can say whatever they
want
okay and that is going to destroy the
country it truly is
okay so here is is how this manifests
for the media so what the media love to
do
in order to make this happen everybody
understands this really ugly thing that
is happening right now
even people who are sort of mainstream
liberals understand that this is an ugly
thing that's why you had the harper's
weekly letter
last year about 150 academics on the
left all of whom voted for biden i'm
sure
not single trump voter among them wrote
a letter to cry and cancel culture
and the left went after them right all
of those people
are being lumped in now with people on
the right and all those people are being
lumped in
with the worst offenders of people who
violate sort of norms of decency
because the goal here is to shut the
overton window so small that no one fits
in it except for the locust
of everybody on a social level so if you
have the right political values by the
way
then you have a free pass to do whatever
you want and if you don't have the right
political values then you have a
pre-pass to do nothing
and we will dig up everything you wrote
back in 2002 and we will use it to ruin
you
so let's take a couple of examples so
right now in politics there are two
stories one is going to receive
significant media attention one is not
going to receive significant media
attention
at least not in the long haul again the
one that's not going to receive
significant attention long haul it's a
story right now so it's gotten a little
bit of mainstream media attention to be
fair
it's not going to receive any over the
course of the next two weeks
the co-founder of the lincoln project
right the lincoln project is a bunch of
supposedly ex-republicans
who went democrats wasted tens of
millions of bucks targeting particular
republicans across the country
and then claimed victory after the last
election cycle it's sort of the most
not only never trump and anti-trump but
anti-republican they were going after
people like susan collins in maine
and so it turns out that the lincoln
project which is basically a bunch of
grifters
who suggested that they were going to
say nasty things about republicans and
raise lots of money to do it it turns
out that the co-founder
john weaver has now been condemned by
the lincoln project in the wake of
allegations that the long-time gop
strategist made unsolicited sexual
overtures to several young men
including one who was 14 years old at
the time he received sexual messages
from weaver
the group finally after i mean there are
reports about this for months by the way
finally the group put out a statement on
sunday when it became clear they
couldn't keep running away from the
story
saying john weaver led a secret life
that was built on a foundation of
deception at every level he's a predator
a liar and an abuser we extend our
deepest sympathies to those who are
targeted by his deplorable and predatory
behavior
the lincoln project rose to prominence
last year as they campaigned against
trump
and others who supported him weaver 61
helped co-found the group
he had previously worked on the
presidential campaigns for john mccain
and john kasich
the new york times published a report
sunday morning based on interviews with
21 men
who alleged weaver sent them unwanted
provocative messages or solicited that
solicited them for sex
often in exchange for the promise of
professional help the new york times
story followed reports
belt weaver's behavior from earlier this
month including one by the american
conservatives ryan gordursky
on january 11th and by axios on january
15th
his original response weavers was that
he was a gay man
which is the get out of jail free card
of sexual abuse at least for a couple of
weeks right is that if you're a straight
guy supposedly who engages in predatory
behavior
claiming you're gay is somehow supposed
to give you cover most gay men are not
predators
when i say most i mean nearly all gay
men are not predators so that's a pretty
pathetic
defense there by uh by weaver
so on sunday the lincoln project noted
weaver was never around the other
members
he said we are grateful beyond words
that at no time was john weaver in the
physical presence of any other member of
the lincoln project okay fine
so this will be out of the news i
promise within three days
and the lincoln project will continue as
though nothing ever happened
because they have issued the the
denunciation of their co-founder
and they will move on okay maybe that's
right maybe that's right maybe they
never knew seriously i'm gonna give them
the benefit of the down maybe they never
knew any of this stuff was true
maybe they never knew that any of the
rumors were true fine
okay do you think that the right is
going to be if they were a right-wing
group
you really think that that'd be let go
within the next few days watch watch the
news
you'll see the mentions of lincoln
project in the news will go like this
right they're just going to crater
meanwhile
every republican in america will be
asked about the crazy person
marjorie taylor green every single
republican for the next couple of years
will be asked every time marjory taylor
greens has a crazy thing
to denounce marjory taylor green because
that's the way this game
works is that if there is somebody on
the right who's crazy and you need
somebody crazy you can focus in on so
you can slander the entire republican
party and every conservative with that
person
you just keep focusing in on that person
right john weaver will not be in the
news
two days from now marjorie taylor green
will be in the news for the next couple
of years at minimum
no matter how many times people say that
she's a crazy person because by the way
she's a crazy person
alrighty so here is the thing you've got
the entire the entire left
basically saying that everybody on the
right has to answer for its
its worst members meanwhile the rule on
the rule on the left is that you never
have to answer for any of your worst
members it's pretty amazing actually
yeah i i've been hearing from folks on
the left why don't you guys on the right
why don't you just guess get rid of your
worst
folks and i say well you know when steve
king said his white supremacy
defense comment right when he said that
thing some of us
went full out for his opponent in a
primary he got primaried he lost
that seat now belongs to to feenstra in
that same district
so i'm just going to note you guys had
nancy pelosi
on the cover of magazines with ilhan
omar
okay ohana omar is an open anti-semite
so is rashida toled they are both openly
anti-semitic
like repeatedly and openly you couldn't
even get a censure vote against those
against those congress people
and the head of your caucus did magazine
covers
with those people and they are cheered
wildly
by the people in your in the media
constantly
and marjorie taylor green does not have
a fan base
outside of her immediate constituency in
georgia okay
i'm wondering who exactly is the giant
fan base
for marjorie taylor green and yet
marjorie taylor green is being treated
as though she is sort of the heroine of
the republican party these days i don't
know where i mean i do know where this
is coming from it's coming from a
motivated
media line of thought that says
republicans are their worst members and
democrats don't have bad members they
don't exist
so for example you're seeing this
barbara lee's democrat of course
and barbara lee she says on cnn of
course
that marjorie taylor green is a danger
she shouldn't serve in any legislative
body and it's just indicative of how bad
the republicans are that she's being
allowed to serve now a couple of things
one she's an elected congressperson
i don't believe that you can inject an
elected congress person based on
comments made before they were a
congress person once they're a
congressperson you can eject them
based on on comments that they make but
if you dig up something they said a year
ago
presumably the people spoke based on
that information
and here's barbara lee making this
particular case
she is a danger she's a threat uh she
refuses to wear
masks she now of course we see
which is to be expected the support of
donald trump
who incited violence who promoted
the attempted coup on january 6 and five
people died
and so she based on who she is her
behavior what she has said
it's she's a danger and should not serve
in uh
any legislative body so i agree she
never should have been elected
to congress i totally agree by the way
the comments that she is referring to
is that marjorie taylor green believes a
bunch of crazy crap cause she's kind of
crazy
now here's the stuff that she has said
according to the sacramento bee she
suggested
in a facebook post that the wildfires in
california
she says there are all these people who
have said they saw what looked like
lasers or blue beams of light
causing the fires and pictures and
videos
and apparently these lasers are
controlled by the jews
which is interesting the post claims
involvement from investor richard blum
husband of senator dianne feinstein and
the banking firm rothschild
inc so apparently she says if they are
beaming
the sun's energy back to earth i'm sure
they would never miss a transmitter
receiving station right
i mean mistakes are never made when
anything new is invented what would that
look like anyway a laser beam or light
beam coming down to earth i guess could
that cause a fire hmm i don't know i
hope not
that sherman look so good for pg e
rothschild zinc solarin or jerry brown
who doesn't seem fond
of pg and e um
she's also trafficked in q anon which is
crazy towns
um and uh she shared social media posts
asserting in 2018
that the parkland shooting was a false
flag operation
okay so she she's a nut she's a nutty
person who was elected
to congress because it was a a small
primary she's the only person who
received any sort of funding or media
attention
and next time around she should not be
elected right and if she says this sort
of stuff while she's in congress then
congress has every ability to eject her
from congress
certainly to censure her okay with all
of that said the attempt to paint
margery taylor green as the face of the
republican party is pretty obvious by
the media that is why there is all this
oppo
focus on marjory taylor green right now
see they can't do it for trump anymore
right trump's gone
so now they have to find a new face of
the republican party so are they gonna
pick
one of the other faces of the republican
party they're gonna pick like dan
crenshaw
no of course not instead they're gonna
pick marge retailer green and attempt to
claim the entire republican party
is in fact marjorie taylor green and
suggest over and over
that republicans are more worried about
about the
the normies within the party than they
are about the march retailer greens
within the party so that's what chris
wallace was doing over the weekend on
fox news
the fox news by the way brian stelter
would like to ban uh here's chris
wallace
saying that there is more focus on lynn
cheney in the republican party than
there is on marjory taylor green
which um i'm not sure how that is the
case considering that every single
republican member i have heard of has
condemned marjorie taylor green's
comments
in any case here's chris wallace you
know you've got a situation right now
where there is more
visible outrage inside the gop
over liz cheney a member of leadership
voting to impeach the president
over rather than some of these wild
conspiracy theories
being espoused by marjorie taylor greene
how serious is this for the gop and what
can they do about it i mean they take
her off committees
expeller what what what are their
options here so a couple of things liz
cheney with regard to impeachment is
obviously doing something that's kind of
more important within the republican
power
party than this fringe nut from georgia
who believes in jewish space lasers
by the way i i can't tell you more about
the jewish space laser
first rule of jewish space laser is you
never talk about jewish space
laser second rule of jewish space lover
a jewish space laser
is and we never roll on chavez those are
the two rules of jewish space laser
but aside from that but the reason that
republicans are
maybe focused on the controversy
surrounding liz cheney is because
impeachment is kind of a big thing and
liz cheney's the number three republican
in the house whereas this lady is a
first-term backbencher from georgia who
probably won't win re-election in her
district
so maybe that that is more of an issue
in the immediate term for
the republican party but the goal here
of course is that every republican is
going to be smeared with
with marjorie taylor green in the same
way that every republican a few years
back was smeared with todd aiken
that is the way this works okay you're
going to hear mtg
margery taylor green repeated over and
over and over again and by the way
because the left does this this is what
they do because the left is going to
spend an
inordinate amount of time the mainstream
media on this person that is going to
drive
people into the arms of this person
because then people would be like why is
this person being unfairly attacked why
is she why are they constantly talking
about her
because she's gonna end up with a larger
following which of course is exactly
what a lot of people want
a lot of people including margaret
taylor green i would assume love that
media attention
because the media focusing on that means
a lot of people in reactionary fashion
will then go and defend mars retailer
green now two things can be true at once
one
she shouldn't be in congress she
believes a lot of crazy crap crazy crap
and two she is not a mainstream
republican voice
she is not the leader of any movement
she is not an important person in the
republican caucus
and she should be primary next time
around by a well-funded opponent
okay but that's not what the media's
designed here is to do the media's
design is to is to create
this this supposed imbalance between
craziness on the right and craziness on
the left
reality check there's craziness on both
sides the crazy people on both sides
need to be condemned i see actually more
condemnation from it very often on the
right than i do from people on the left
again the left just wants to pretend
away the idea that there is any sort of
similarity between the craziness
okay the craziness extends across the
aisle i saw an entire democratic party
look the other way or cheer while cities
burn during the summer
and then when the capital riots happen
they're like why are you guys on the
right not condemning the violence more
strenuously
some of us condemn the violence both
times guys some of us thought it was
evil
both times some of you are just full of
crap
and when you do the same thing with
marge retailer green well you wrap your
large-scale democratic embrace around
ilhan omar and pretend that she's a
leading figure in your movement
i'm gonna say that you guys don't have a
leg to stand on when you talk about
anti-semitism in your own party
especially given the fact that your
entire critical race theory nonsense
is rooted in anti-semitic perceptions
about how jews are not actually a
victimized people
jews are actually just successful white
people now asians are turning into white
people thanks to critical race theory
so yeah i i don't buy any of your your
phony
insanity about this rando
weirdo crazy person yeah i i think that
it's a little bit i think it's a little
bit convenient
that you've decided to elevate margery
taylor green to the leadership of the
republican party based on zero evidence
that she's a member of the leadership of
the republican party
that is the goal here fringe everybody
by pointing at this by pointing at this
one person then that allows you to
basically silence anybody
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content